alors allez pas oui je sais on va
d'ailleurs parce que l'agenda
il y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
belle sortie dans mobinil
[Musique]
à
ah ah
à bord tout
voilà
il
[Musique]
les dessins
il y a
avec
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
identifié mais toujours là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on s'est suffisamment ont tenu loin les
uns des autres
évidemment ces derniers mois pour avoir
un grand plaisir à se retrouver ce soir
une grande célébration un grand
réveillon à partager ensemble et avec
pas mal de copains de la famille
musicale aussi chez la culture reprend
ses droits reprend le contrôle de la
scène
parmi eux mars et je sème beroard
anthony de route chéri saint-honoré pour
ne citer qu'eux parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de gens et surtout
beaucoup de surprises à suivre dans
cette émission
au programme de cette émission vous avez
la part belle aussi forcément puisque on
va basculer en mode karaoké les paroles
de tubes est ce que titre de succès
intergénérationnel vont se succéder sur
votre écran histoire que vous nous en
boîtier le pas que vous ambiancer où
vous soyez aux quatre coins de la
martinique dans des lieux iconique
également bienvenue dans boucles vocales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la partie
[Musique]
oh
mais ça
[Musique]
et
si tous les jours
yao
et c'est parti pour la soirée pour m
c est toi françois les bourthois et
quatre en tout temps mettra t 6 s'est
montré des six secondes ne m'ont pas là
[Musique]
aussi du mans
oh
[Musique]
et billy walsh a pris
ce soir le poids de ligue des champions
par exemple ou le temple de ses shows
qui allait gagner mais comme on n'est
pas en soi une cause qui voleraient elie
à l'école attend en accord est attendu
[Musique]
la paix
on est seul
genève
ap ap à laissé dix corps humain qu'un
groupe emma en mon équipe est passée qui
fait pas français c'est parce un peigne
qui les sépare la peine de frapper à
l'été lit comme un gameplay au monde qui
perd pas c'est l'amour qui fait par ryan
dans le seesus que traîne dans madinina
[Musique]
tout le monde
le bailleur aussi don
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
le
chaque fois moins qu'à au danemark a
senti moins ces termes par sac villa
sise au modem arriverait l'a6 ou aux
divers attisons mahzem à 23h54 aux
antilles où il assiste au musée maritime
ouanna 6 ou moins nouveau volet
glissement des mains du manager moque la
paroisse six mois la saison redémarre y
at il ou elle assiste au dessus vous l
assise aux mains de marie attirer la
saison happy when à six hommes en se
mariant tiguan assise au moins dix
prévoient l'église voix de marie maladie
aux démocrates paroisse je travaillais
[Musique]
mon amour
m
[Musique]
t
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
mon petit gars amies abby
[Musique]
ouaip annulation des moyens du bord et
maritime au cachot
[Musique]
d
cette année
[Musique]
sa peine
nous allons aller
d'autres
[Musique]
d
visés
tél
pas de nier
à temps
madame
[Musique]
mais
ça
[Musique]
obama
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
talât
déposé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de sublimes images de san jose avait
probablement peut-être saint-joseph
comme vous ne l'avez jamais vue sublime
et encore qui plus est par monsieur marc
c'est qu'on retrouvera un petit peu plus
tard dans l'émission debout quand boukai
parce qu'il a encore bien des instants à
nous offrir pour dire au revoir à 2020
direction celle cher pour l'instant et
c'est jean-luc guanel j'espère que vous
connaissez les paroles et même si vous
ne connaissez pas les paroles c'est
l'occasion justement de ne pas vous
tromper en les suivant sur votre écran
voici sweet ses doudous
[Musique]
derrière
je
[Musique]
nous sommes en pointe vers l'est par
l'état pas accroché
[Musique]
si les hommes
faux
sa page facile
comment
ça
ce sens
[Musique]
changer
mélange d'apathie
et comment
[Musique]
anglais
anticiper
[Musique]
c'est
c
[Musique]
je
l'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
suite
[Musique]
nous
c
non
[Musique]
la tasse
quoi
[Musique]
c'est
ma nation on va chanter ça
[Musique]
lui
on y va
[Musique]
vue là
si je
et
ce
[Musique]
nou ka danser
ça
[Musique]
m
chante pas
[Musique]
vraiment pas mal d'ambiance à schoelcher
merci jean luc guanel on se retrouve
tout à l'heure ça qu'a sonné dans
d'autres communes aussi
et d'ailleurs je vous emmène du côté du
lamentin imaginez retracé la carrière de
pline voici un medley avec ses plus gros
moment de carrière à revivre tout de
suite évidemment en karaoké dans l'e
book en bocal derrière imaginer un
hommage aussi un artiste que vous aimez
beaucoup pour découvrir lequel rester
avec nous il sera interprété par anthony
d'euros
[Musique]
au point où tu es à mende a compté
ma
enfin tombée d'un débat tech
pont-de-salars
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui la bat yam où il est tombé
20 personnes pour sa cicatrice et mon
sentiment n'est pas bien ce qu'il a dit
pape elle prend ces personnes mais
j'habite ici les mêmes motifs était elle
[Musique]
aime beaucoup
tellement qu'elle levait
1 en fait qu'on est salement vinet
[Musique]
il n'a trouvé ça stupide ces tentatives
de suicide
pourquoi pour lui vouloir se jeter dans
le
[Musique]
c'est ça
koeman je me sens responsable lorsque tu
pètes ce câble moutons je croyais tout
et sa main sur mon portable dans ma vie
instable des trop-perçus comptable mais
j'avoue que tu mais indispensable je me
sens responsable
lorsque tu fait un simple bouton joie
j'ai tout est là mais sur mon portable
dans ma vie instable et pour pc
portables mais djabou coutume est
indispensable tu m'appelles à des heures
impossibles sur mon portable je suis
fait flipper je ne sais pas de quoi tu
es capable
demandez jamais pensé détruisent
épouvantable on m'avait payé le
lendemain j'étais capable
ses parents dit comment je prends la
tête je me sens plus bas y'a tout
laisser et les mains quand on nous
arrête pour un sommeil et les maires et
b
[Musique]
globalement lauder important pour moi
pour l'influent pis rien bay - ça
s'arrête en aillant de vie des 15,6 me
dis même pas lancé pense qu'à manille
lankais
je pense pas
m
pour dj dim et palop c'est parce que
moins il argué
c'était moi qu'un procès
communauté
c'est du moins qu'un par l'otan
macabre
c'est du moins la volonté
mon colonel vous ni moins comme un autre
[Musique]
ça y est
full spec
le faux débat
[Musique]
où
si tu joues quitter pompey toulouse
grand outil tellement tellement
[Musique]
la maison fait
c'est pas au bal folk etc
[Musique]
schaper
après dix années
[Musique]
l'obligé ait
ce qu'on aime
pépy au pinceau
qui
vous imitez
[Musique]
eux-mêmes pas plus et si luca sortie en
3d
le bénin
[Musique]
ouais
parce que m'avait pas trahi leurs
repères mâché ses mots ce droit qui
toussait qui campaient
[Musique]
si on veut sauver qui toussait kick off
mais pas
asus est
au pouvoir
poulin beau tout
ou ailleurs
pour eux
pour le vote
ouais
6h10 agnès tu sais
taïga
qu'est qu'on pense à 6
[Musique]
et bouaké
sus aux pratiques
[Musique]
c'est quand tu es gamin qu'est moins
qu'un constat
c'est simple
c'est qu'ici c'est long
sega est moi qui comprend
six semaines
[Musique]
si vite et si sa rivale si si c'est
facile
non des égards
c'est ici
[Musique]
on quitte l'époque patrick saint-eloi
mais on va garder la nouvelle génération
l'occasion de revenir à nos jours avec
l'oeil sont déjà d'abord émaillé
s'ensuivra la présence également de
maurane voyez très remarquée évidemment
pendant cette année 2009 avec notamment
son album bazaar dont le titre qui va
suivre n'est pas extrait à suivre doudou
juste après maille et les boucans boukai
continue
[Musique]
e
à
ou 10 km 1
[Musique]
ma gueule
mais si ces putschs et mer
simek vous guider
you came au sommeil
maï maï
si c'est pour lapider 6 mai
[Musique]
banny longtemps nous je ne me mets pas
les 12 matthew warchus anne lacaton
toujours on n'est pas moyen tu as connu
par bayer joussot ou du hockey démaillé
mais si ces boues gmail
simek how it et y aller
zuckerberg est lapidé coucher ma vessie
mais où qui tenait
oui oui mais n'oublie pas des novices et
les soufflets pas de moyens mais l'envié
écoutez ça tape à l'oeil jeudi ou km le
maillot
mais si c'est pour un schéma
simek un loup qui sait rien
[Musique]
si c'est pour la vie des couches et même
si mais oublié
aucun des onze ya eu des fois qu'il est
appelé
que ces derniers passent à 12h06 part
consacré ces locales et des ponts athéna
line jalousie j'ai sorti mon ami m'a
l'air est sabre au cosip lazio dont j'ai
pas tout dit uk
[Musique]
mais si ces bougies men
si beckham ou qui s'est dit ou pas
6 mai ou qui
ou disons salle des totems en effet
poussé jean memory balle est trop fort
huit chaînes comme pour cette bio
papandreou s'est enorgueilli nombre à
battre ces paroles ou quoi tient la
route à la houppe at-elle aop moitié des
cas chez ima gâtés qui tchèque ivan
hasek a échappé pouvait pas se louper ça
[Musique]
il
would you came démaillé
non
bah si c'est boudjima
ces lyonnais
ou qu'elles m'ont réveillé
ma vie
sur ce coup-là gauche et même
si vous quittez la pièce
[Musique]
à la maison ou à la maison
vous chantez avec nous mallet alors on
se met debout au sort du canapé comment
se met bien cette semaine
cette sphère
attention à tous avec vous mais vous
avec la cei à gaza moody ou games des
mains ou
mais si ces bougies man et simek et/ou
quitté y aller
voulzy ou quémander mais si c'est pour
la vie des couches minces
m
[Musique]
mais si ces bouquets maman 6 mai camou
quitté hier
m
c'est plus la pide touché main
si vous quittez
et
[Applaudissements]
marie
ma vie
[Musique]
si maigre ou qui c'est y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
notre temps
tendre 2
on crée nos sentiments on a peur d'aller
plus loin
mais ce soit plus seul changera car je
reste avec toi sous les étoiles
qu'ils videront pétards
[Musique]
dis-moi con
- de tay problème là
et la baisse mais
confiance ce soir
au bac et qu'on est désolé
et si tel est le cas cette fois
manquaient toujours
oddo jallet
[Musique]
m
et bijoux
chan
et puis
alors bien faire ta balle
[Musique]
est une surprise bon
l'eau
ce que te
détruire v - confiance ce soir ou pki
qu'on est tous les décideurs
abattoir monde
chaillet
mais non
et bebo
j'allume
m
et pivot et puis jean mérault paie 10 -
finish à et moi donc
aux jeunes il faut aimer
au fait moi
m
j'aime
mais moins qu'attendu
et puis aussi des voyages efforts
constate un essor l'epani place au doute
bien trop courte pause m
m
2 2
[Musique]
chaillot
et puis vous même
et bebo
[Musique]
doudou
aimez vous
doudou shy'm
b
non
[Musique]
dgo deux momies ce2
de nous
[Musique]
évidemment on aurait rêvé cette liste
encore plus longue pour les invités de
boucan bocal pour enflammer votre chez
vous ce soir malheureusement la
situation sanitaire ne le permettait pas
heureusement en revanche il y a du
talent en martinique qui nous permet de
rendre présent justement c'est ce absent
et ne vont pas nous manquer la preuve
avec ray monia moko direction celle cher
dans un court instant avec un fabuleux
medley de fanny jane en a fait une
marque de fabrique est juste avant c'est
thierry saint-honoré qui nous accueille
à fort de france pour rendre un fervent
hommage à pipo martelly
[Musique]
mazars pas donc avancé adam mon méchant
soumaré
perso me sert à rien s'ils récoltent pas
aujourd'hui l'espoir c'est pour l'année
prochaine ont aussi pu tout cas par la
boue
[Musique]
un panneau cas
m
[Musique]
qui choisit
chaque matière
m
[Musique]
le trou nous mais ça vaut débrouillant
pour s'offrir tous parlent
[Musique]
ce qu'on explique à chanter baby loup
les paroles s'affiche juste là c'est
pour vous chez nous
[Musique]
sa peau
à toulouse
[Musique]
oh
quoi
[Musique]
mais
non
on
wen
[Musique]
or
non
[Musique]
parce
c'est que tu
[Musique]
ce faire
ap
m
[Musique]
tous rapports
chanter chez vous accompagnez une benne
en serbie peau
chinois at-il dit bennati
couché
[Musique]
vitalla
ouais
soro
mayer
[Musique]
regardez
c'est pas qu'on y est
[Musique]
non
chaque fois
le chaulier
quand jean matin où elle et moi quelle
poussée bien mangent moins pour ma
personne
j'aimerais qu'on y est clos
c'est
[Musique]
d'après mme en auge à passer mais
pour imager après la plaisance
je ne
[Musique]
les mauvaises mais si oui
qu'elles chauffent et à nos goûts de nos
biens cédés
nous préservons
oh
si nous présente
[Musique]
civ
que je fais comme nous tous qui sait
[Musique]
bon dieu prend patience et b -
cameron ou toujours pas donné à la boue
car ni pour nous tous mozart faits m'ont
radié chimères montré moins cbi - et
tout
[Musique]
il faut au moins par gary
a tous je souhaite une excellente année
[Musique]
ma
temis de tout des prises de nous
arrivé jusqu'au cou
j'espère pour nous
le cours du temps
manitou
il
tu connais
quoique tout
[Musique]
mieux
que tu perds
e
sympa
coup ci se montre à vous le compte à
rebours a sonné comme s'ils souhaitent
plutôt que toni de clamer tout perdre et
sont jetés
six semaines
six mois
moncler
[Musique]
quand tu lèves
bon
moi je suis ton flow tu me mets moi
aucun souci plus ce soir on n'atteindra
pas la police ne vieux oui tu
[Musique]
mutuelle
témoin
[Applaudissements]
m
oui c'est vous
[Musique]
moi jamais
ça
[Musique]
ce pas
on sort ça
[Musique]
fête à 3
je continue tous ces efforts fait
l'histoire sûrement déjà mort
[Musique]
mais j'ai envie d'y croire encore
et si
quand
dix ans vient jabot médecin
oh
[Musique]
à mi amor comment voter
m
se taire c'est un peu moi
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime comme ça
[Musique]
on finira classeur
comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour votre apport au kosovo
[Musique]
jusqu'à demain
je perds
cancer
[Musique]
je t'aime
au champion
son
non
la connaissez
[Musique]
mon petit cachet
je préfère le décor patiemment bien
je ne touche le bout du doigt je
l'espère
[Musique]
encore
son corps
ces chants je suis avec lui mon condo
au coeur
à prive la légende
cb
[Musique]
je touche du bout des doigts et je pèse
pas
[Musique]
encore
bon
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et sow
sow
au zoo
et
[Musique]
son corps
ça
ça bouge son corps son année
tesson
bon
soleil
au soleil
on ajouté chez eux et bon
sow
oh
soleil on
bon
devant ce beau soleil bobo sauve du
soleil moussanais
je vaux
le
pas
[Musique]
il y en a plus
un ton délire c'est toi qui joues c'est
mignon mais la 6e place watchou
déflation n'est pas tabou jusqu'à 100
watts ou toi quand tu es toi demi à 6
sec c'était pour cette élève mon père
qui parlait pas je bluffe da cruz à
kuljic amener à quoi s'est tous jeté
dans la rue
oh
[Musique]
je ne
asie dont vont les
[Musique]
les petites mains
si sa musique
si celui-ci
[Musique]
deux autres
concert
m
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les
le puissant fille
[Musique]
je voit la vie en bleu
mon coeur me
pas
teulet retrait de points
songe à porter à la fois un couteau
la qualité
[Musique]
je vois la vie en
ça va
je veux la vie
pour
stocker l'eau
et
[Musique]
ok
poire n'en reste pas
[Musique]
ce jeu là
les mois ci entre elle et toi il est
question d'amour du mois retire
sable
quand c'est mon tour
c'est une famille
discours comment tu procèdes
échappé bonjour
c'est babu
la tête tout jeudi dans l'est
la poule
[Musique]
tu sens
jeudi dans les
[Musique]
je te vois
m
baboo
[Musique]
tous
tél
je veux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi tu fais quoi
après tout ne pourra pas faire
j'ai dû pratiquer le temps à trinec
[Musique]
vous tente
au jour que ce soit
[Musique]
je continue
car je passe de touché de la tête
je m'en vais
deux cents
j
sans son côté pas beau
[Musique]
je
tutu
détenus
non
je vais
et
[Musique]
il
à ce stade de notre réveillon et à ce
stade de l'émission de boucan bocage
vous avez bien compris la mécanique
c'est un karaoké alors du coup comme on
est plutôt à l'aise ensemble et merci de
nous suivre d'ailleurs on va enchaîner
avec une petite difficulté
supplémentaire allez on ne regrette on
passe un cran au dessus avec une petite
chorégraphie l'oeil sont déjà dans un
instant avec son cultissime cauchy tête
mais juste avant et comme du coup je
sors notre entre un jeu sans votre
présence
j'ai envie de vous dérouter un peu on
part d'abord à saint joseph avec mars et
on va là planté cette graine de l'amour
cette graine lomu dont on aura besoin en
[Musique]
bassoues c'est vraiment chouette
c'est ici
[Musique]
m
voilà
[Musique]
marché
mon nom oui
[Musique]
habillé pagny femme ou pa ka maché ou
kpn et 6 mai mais rochât
c'est parce qu il yal ou sensuelles
comme d'habitude en cas imagine une oie
d'ayant d'altitude russes ont réussi un
7 6 condamne ce que vous aller ou pas
c'est luca congi tel kosice
aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
aïe
pas scénographe auchy tél logitech tout
à
on passait lougratte roshi peut-être
aussi des ouailles mais c'est un bon
chiffre d'affaires à ses ouailles
miyoshi 7,6 pour valser obiang pour
l'âme et où jacques à des novillos
copier le kiosque à l'audimat et nick
fry négociait à yahia est étouffée
tourne mal pour café chase prenait
concours
messier poutou classe ou pas bio
personnes tout l'avion soit
[Musique]
allez
saleh au passé nous gravons chicago sud
est où
[Musique]
vous passez donc la bullshit qui s'est
même aux basques des mais ça paye en la
situant quand même tous pareils et
méconnu dans les pouilles benitez la vie
à mystic hyper fin nouvelle contrôle des
skis de madame mais c'est pour tout
bagage un pur bijou matériaux triés pas
la manquer
sensuelle comme d'habitude qu'à imagine
ou à des attitudes en voyage aqsiq en
place deux pouces en l'air ou pas c'est
lukaku chicago chez soi
[Musique]
aïe
passé
allez
aïe
où habitez paris by géographe là
ce gros cube rosheim touche mon mode ou
cathy et les coyotes se considérait au
profit financier il faut toutefois ses
défauts ses préjugés pour nous ça paye
encore fait
à
[Musique]
aia
vous allez vous passez donc la pochette
[Musique]
vous passez le grossiste est possible
celle de la mairie
c'est le soja pour la fin de l'année
en fait pour en connaître en fait on
doit tous le meilleur ou la nouvelle
année la santé l'avait larmes au web
/ amy attention royal où au climat
si c'est pour aller au passé nous
caressions chaillot en corrèze j'espère
que vous passer une agréable soirée on
ne peut continuer sans saluer la
performance de marché et à ses côtés le
ballet tchè kréyol à qui on fait un
énorme coup coup j'espère que vous en
profite également pour re découvrir ces
lieux absolument magnifique il faut
désormais se réapproprier avec les
lumières des boues cambo kayes la
lumière des boues cambo cas il vous
emmène désormais vers celle cher avec
jean-luc guanel et comparaisons on
accueillera également maurane dans un
petit instant avec le titre de l'année
2020 sentimentale d'ailleurs pour dire
bye bye à 2020 et bienvenue à 2021
[Musique]
1 3 6 6
tant pis c'est tout
la banque embourbée
pas
c'est ça cesse
du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a
[Musique]
chèrement des cités
je
[Musique]
c'est la peau
oh
nous attendons
[Musique]
en vue
pussy
[Musique]
on voit deux
tous
au cours
jean
[Musique]
tha
oui
comparaison
[Musique]
c
- 2
les
monde
beaucoup
ici
je vous
yvette
[Musique]
en gros
ou pas
[Musique]
ma
c
moi tu es
deux corps
santé
[Musique]
pourquoi
c'est
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]
oh
comment de
[Musique]
pourquoi
or
[Musique]
oh
moi
[Musique]
photo
des conflits
[Musique]
bon vous la connaissez normalement si
vous connaissez pas on va apprendre tous
ensemble petit pour une rapide 31
décembre et bien ok a laissé passer il
est chez nous aimons dix ans les
collines boisées antigua et mais
trouvant mon niqab - mgi à l'estomac
il a peur de dire ses potes que pour lui
les meufs sait pas que de la belle
il a peur d'assumer ce qu'ils consomment
encore cindy faut juste qu'elle se taise
le forme entre sa musculature vers le
pont c'est plus fun qu'un montrer sa
culture et on serait là dans sa jambe
ils doivent demander film another
à vos sentimentale
mais
la d'humains
alors répondre
et bien non mais dr
entre autres
mais il a du mal
alors ils bombent le torse
desbiens
beau gosse il exploite depuis les gants
les truites qc son heure de gloire dans
la vraie vie quand ils croisent à
financer
ni sens on va voir vainqueur page est
dans un monde de brutes ou de le
modifier et une méchante insultes et
joue au quinté ce qu'on lui demande et
en fait c'est dommage
un sentiment tout
mais il a vu main
[Musique]
le tas
c'est dans mon adn
il a du mal
c'est un sentiment terre mais la dîme
je veux le mental je suis me point rouge
cet assentiment terre mais il a du mal à
me demande technique il est celle qui
passe après bodji en lettonie en papier
glacé au maintien dans médée
[Musique]
et là d'une main
alors qu'on attend
non
dimanche
il a du mal
du bon temps
et en mai
les tchèques mois et bondi en estrie
il est chaque point
il est maudit en occasions
du beurre dans médée
[Musique]
passer un bon réveillon
si on y réfléchit c'est un des rares
moments très agréables de 2020 que la
sortie de l'album de maurane voiliers
dont est extrait sentimentale un album
bazar et je lui souhaite un grand bruit
pour la suite de sa carrière
mine de rien voilà un titre qui a
véritablement confirmé son émergence sur
la scène antillo guyanaise alors mine de
rien il ya quelques années il y à un
gentil bug un peu plus mûr maintenant
qui est exactement à la même place et le
succès qu'il a fait connaître ses - love
anthony drew est à suivre dans la
séquence à venir direction fort de
france et puis juste après si vous êtes
assez approché et que vous ne trouvez
pas ça assez rétro - love on monte
vraiment des années en arrière avec une
chanson que tout le monde connaît que
tout le monde va entonner où que vous
soyez celle de pline avec gas des
réalités à sète au programme de boucan
bocage
[Musique]
oh
dans mon oncologue ou de ce qu on y est
pour sauver jean la vie gut s'est vite
en ciel se quitter tenir et en solaire
si on joue dauphine de mountain view
devant l'éternel a quitté montée
j'ai senti qu'on cycle où elle avoue
passe mal l'homme
[Musique]
nicosie le portrait ce mélo
dialogue a senti moins loeb
[Musique]
jelavic ou divine ou dans sept journaux
finement l'autre ayant demandé
comme si tu aimes ou tu étais trop mal
de fonctions et l'avocat pont
m
i comme elle avoue m'assois local
récente ou
[Musique]
anticons cycle mais la semaine
m
si le temps d'apprendre vincini des
pensées qui a permis d'enlever tout
nombre d'hommes
oui mais aucune au bout ça
ça
monteux femme fait preuve le sang
[Musique]
santi gossip powell à poupet à saint
malo 1
pour moi
le goût
c'est con sic mais le groupe mas mais
l'offre
là
voix sinon tu seras viré cinquième porte
laisse séance et non des chinois
le foehn le patient tisser et quand
c'est lent c'est bon et plus on avance
le coeur a ses raisons
c'est bien d'en faire
[Musique]
oh
c'est con sic vrai
la semelle au sens
[Musique]
twc est là pour passe mais l'ordre
la lorraine
le
[Musique]
santi concis clair elle avoue passe mal
oh
[Musique]
le
hélas
santi concis clamerait lavaud passe mal
lors
[Musique]
galaga centimes au nord
je ne peux pas éviter ou v6 ou garder
les invités mais qui comprend que
magenta cette façon c'est ans est mort
en capter et je peux chanter les tubes
vallourec un trouble et mathieu bois
pouvais me faut maintenant passer basso
s'est passé mon cap et méchant pas
quoique à trouver mais tous y gagnent
des places mais moins long terme a
renchéri en coûtera 10 kms en boucle un
sapin trop beau maillot et le maillet
imad nommé au vih et au bruit opb yola
coup de folie faune et yeux non tout
pensé pour d'oignons rappelle l'agencé
paquito maillot le mot allah nous
réserve
mais pourquoi on m'a gentiment clapet
[Musique]
nico braun dans ma jambe à cette façon
c'est pas seulement 100 km/h en 6 pôles
brega mais matthew g toujours poignonnec
l'oseille et bon marché mais passionné
toujours loin devant soi des passions
mais qu'on paye ou ses classiques de
guespin alcool bayod tellement goyo
boulevard lui trouver cailloux et ce
grâce à young a profité tellement yo
cabaye ofac
vous verrez au ghanéen d'été
les démons en faisant passer personne
s'est passé mon brevet
[Musique]
meetic obama jean basset basso
fabricants pouvaient même chose oui j'ai
navigué maslacquais convaincre la fifa
mais parions qu'à des coûts - ya moins
de 400 bouteilles au coach que ma chance
à mammoth ayo cocoon the do you can t
get en produits sanguins
keyyo mon copain c'est que les gens là
ne m'ont pas plu quand calais
[Musique]
pas-de-calais pour abc et yang oublions
pas payant pas ses mots
[Musique]
tout le monde a faim
plus tôt
un cochon bonne année
sempé
amor unités
vous savez ce qu'on dit en bonne
compagnie on ne s'ennuie pas et le
compte à rebours est bel et bien amorcée
on a fait notre maximum au boucan bocal
pour vous rapprocher de l'effusion des
voeux qui va s'ensuivre évidemment pour
la bascule vers cette nouvelle année et
pour cette nouvelle année on va
forcément éclairer le chemin avec les
artichauts mais aussi en ligne de jeux
super war on ira également à la
rencontre de l'isie kananga avec comme
si c'est son cadeau pour ces fêtes de
fin d'année sans oublier l'incroyable
énergie de lauriane zachary qui revisite
le cultissime sos détective de quartier
suiza a tout de suite
[Musique]
direct
dans tout seul à 6 ans cloud rock a
songé manque atteint tout ça qui fait
moins monter des sans voix la voix
toujours des mêmes jours et puis pas de
la vie
qui vont l'être
un peu
tombée dans les mains
chaque on m'avait menti sa cuvée
août est évidemment faux et l'idée
laisse locaux messiaen la cpaci
au trésor
mais manqua son jet sanou tpf
si le pâté jambon
m
c'est même rivière en outre abaissé et
maussade
là
[Musique]
on
et nous tombait pas quel accueil lui
matière
[Musique]
m
patientez
[Musique]
passé
oh
[Musique]
à
mais c'est faux
[Musique]
au fond
m
[Musique]
oh
ça
tous
à son géant qu'attend tout ça qui fait
moi même
la voix toujours dit vrai papa
parmi eux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin
hier
était en libye
magalas et compliqué fès a loupé pour
nous passer en belle hausse au japon ne
dit si tu penses que tu penses
prions pour que savons tous ici tu
penses y ait quelqu'un qui pense radelet
financier aucun sens où ça ce que je
chante
comme si on veut mais couplé bas j'adore
regardez pas et puis j'avais comme si
chaque jour effet le dernier
c'est ça
écoutez moi j'attends si on ne me
regardez pas évident
[Musique]
tellement puissant très bon finisseur
sans souci
[Musique]
et puis j'appuie
m
il
on veut m'écouter moi j'attends
on ne me regardez pas
et comme ça
chaque jour et elles
c'est pareil au palais au palais fédéral
et non c'est tout et tout les jours je
serai de ceux qui veulent trouver et ce
qu'ils pouvaient
car ce qui te manipule qui vous habite
ne soit pas ce portrait du personnage au
bâton
on ne m'écoute et si on ne regardait pas
vie d'un homme
ici
les visas puis comme si chaque jour
c'est en ce sens que si nous proposons
ne nous définit sera m désolé mon ami on
regarde scène par souci parce que je ne
m'écoute moi je tends ma main car des
lois et puis j'ai appris comme si
sage
on est pas
k
des visas puis
comme si chacune était de gagner demain
allah
non
[Musique]
là
par qui
[Musique]
souffrez royal
c'est moi
ce n'est pas
parler
[Musique]
tous les cas
ces mêmes stars nhl en battant tous ses
cadets nos souhaits à brasser des autres
soit plus à briller les meilleurs vous
pas tout me respecte mon année leurs
mots pour toujours
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous lever et danser
à machecoul kg
[Musique]
car nager mais si la nouvelle
bizarre c'est vrai nouvelle
[Musique]
marchesseau dinan - tous au parc n'y a
pas débat
[Musique]
tu y vois mot bâle ville à lloret cet
acte i scène et acteur du mena
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux côtés
[Musique]
m
t
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la charge
ngo bao chau des sondés
banimmo cela
[Musique]
balisage part j'ai
mba obame et des pétards
oui
cet accident
[Musique]
zizou kilowatts constate ici nous avons
des actifs
[Musique]
c'est mon prono de se quitter en
espérant vous avoir ouvert la plus belle
passerelle vers l'année prochaine une
année pour se revoir c'est tout ce qu'on
se souhaite une année des plus heureuses
des plus belles remerciement tout
particulier également aux équipes
techniques aux musiciens aux artistes
évidemment tous ceux qui ont été
mobilisés au nom évidemment de martinez
que la première je vous souhaite une
très très bonne année
[Musique]
l'api
à
[Musique]
souffrez royal
cd
le palais
[Musique]
tous les quatre ans
encore une fois
[Musique]
j'essaye même si tard elle a rétrogradé
sa solide rochelle en bout parvenant à
tous ces cadeaux souhaitable grâce et d
autre qu elle soit prêt à briller les
meilleurs vous pas tout me respecte
bonne année leurs mots pour toujours